Salve! Come cosa sto facendo? Ma ovviamente la demonetizzazione mi ha portato cercare un altro lavoro
un vero lavoro
faccio l'arbitro di incontri di boxe adesso. No no, questa è una nuova puntata di beviamoci su
Nel senso che a sto giro sarò io il barista ed altri a raccontare le loro storie
non penserete che io sia l'unico ad avere dei fan particolari...
Non avete idea!
Non è vero signor Merrino?
Quindi ero al cinema con la mia ragazza
ed eravamo andati a vedere Claudatus[?]
Già quando siamo entrati avevamo sentito:"Ahh Marco Merrino, Marco Merrino!"
Gente che ovviamente deve solamente dire il nome, senza salutare o niente
e pensavo, come molte volte succede, che sarebbe finita là.
E' accaduto che... allora ho scelto questa storia perché
Sì ne sono successe di più strane, ma questa è SINGOLARE
Anche perché le altre le ho prese a ridere, questa qua l'ho preso molto a:"Facciamoci un film sopra"
Siamo tornati a casa
apro la casella di posta e
mi era arrivato un minuto prima quindi questa persona l'ha mandato
perché si trovava al cinema
nero
Con quella che presumo sia la tua ragazza e lo schermo davanti bianco
Quindi tutto qua e... qual è il numero della polizia?
Va beh almeno la foto l'ha fatta, voglio dire... Ci sono tanti appassionati poi che ti conoscono molto meglio della tua stessa famiglia
E sanno molto meglio di loro quali sono le tue vere passioni
Vero signor Fraus? Per quanto riguarda ragazzi che seguono parliamo di videogiochi per me che sono una persona
Molto timida sono capitate tantissime situazioni, su mezzi pubblici o comunque luoghi dove non puoi fare rumore di
situazioni
Rumorosissime e parecchio imbarazzanti ma alla fine ti fanno piacere ma
Gli incontri più bizzarri sono magari agli eventi o nei luoghi di incontro dove magari qualcuno viene da me dice ehi senti io ti seguo
Ma ti ho conosciuto per il canale delle armi o altre persone che dicono senti io non
Seguo I videogiochi però visto. I tuoi video sulle armi e sono principalmente appartenenti alle forze dell'ordine
Persone che fanno tiro dinamico e poi ci sono anche guardie giurate
E persone che hanno il porto d'armi a difesa personale per questi ultimi si creano le situazioni più divertenti perché si parla dell'argomento
poi ad un certo punto
Si arriva a parlare dell'arma utilizzata in servizio o che sia ha addosso e lì poi parte la domanda mia:
"Ma, ce l'ha con te l'arma?" lui fa:"Sì."
la vuoi vedere
si
ragazzi arrivo subito e lì si va o all'interno della macchina della persona si va in un bagno si va in un luogo più appartato
E tranquillo si tira fuori l'arma si inizia ad a analizzare
Qualcuno magari l'ha anche smontata mi fa vedere magari munizioni particolari che ha acquistato che magari si possono/non si possono utilizzare
determinati contesti e
queste sono diciamo le situazioni più surreali ma anche
Divertenti mi siano capitate con l'utenza che mi segue quanto è vero c'è veramente un sacco di gente
Che adorerebbe guardare la canna della mia pistola se capite cos'è il peggio sto parlando. Del mio pene
La passione che alcuni di voi hanno va. Oltre il mero essere fan c'è quell'invisibile linea di demarcazione
Dettata dal proprio schermo. Del computer che divide il fan
Dal pubblico vero signor sa ma cu a me capita spessissimo
Davvero di ricevere meravigliose esternazioni d'affetto rispetto e stima uniche
però non posso negare che capitino effettivamente 20
Su chi vien voglia di berci suo comunque rifletterci un po 1 stranezze
Dolcissime viene ed emozione ma
Stranezze a una delle mie prime fiere un ragazzo mi avvicino
molto investito molto serio
E medie di dei consigli fortis molto molto rigidi sul mio lavoro mi disse di fare certe cose di, non
fare altre cose e quindi
Guardandomi negli occhi mi disse ti ho fatto un dono estremamente importante tienilo sempre con te non perderlo è cruciale
Davvero era molto serio e mi dite questa scatola e io aprì con estrema emulsione interesse anche perché comunque
Lo prendevo molto sul serio indipendentemente da chi tu sia meriti tutta l'attenzione del mondo
Dentro c'era una pallina di quelle fosforescenti rimbalzine con un occhio disegnato sopra
E trovo ancora qui la uso come honda energetica per un'action figure di goku ma
Ho il terrore che sia una sorta di device di controllo qualcosa del genere
scherzandoci sopra
perché è stato molto strano vedere quella pallina
E vedere la serietà con cui ma la data
Certo ma soprattutto sotto natale per quanto riguarda, I regali
Basta il pensiero anche se quel pensiero potrebbe essere una macumba africana però è numericamente più fame e più situazioni
del genere ti ritrovi
Soprattutto se le ai milioni di fan vero signor fa vj. Un
Anno un annetto fa mi siedo
Al tavolo di un ristorante
inizia a mangiare e trovo sul tavolo un
giornale leggo il giornale leggo un articolo in particolare che attira la mia attenzione
Due ragazze di 14
E 15 anni più o meno scappano dal centro italia e vengono ritrovate al nord
dopo un giorno
nel mio paesino dove abitavo
Io prima e la scusa di queste ragazze dopo che l'hanno ritrovata è stata siamo scappate per andare ad incontrare
una persona che abbiamo conosciuto online
Io che so che in quel paesino ci abitano veramente tre persone in croce ci abitavo, io e due vecchi
Sapevo la realtà dei fatti mentre leggeva. Il giornale ero così
chiudo il giornale lo metto via
E ho mangiato il resto. Del cibo con molto sforzo
E basta e santi dio e che e ci sono varie tipologie di pubblico in base alla tipologia
Del tuo canale c'è chi al pubblico giovane c'è chi al pubblico misto poi c'è chi anche al pubblico adulto
vero signor shy di breaking italy
visto quello che faccio su youtube o un pubblico un po più adulto di quello che è
Normalmente si pensa siano le persone che seguono youtube quindi venticinquenni trentenni avevo strettamente di confini mi capita spesso coppia
passeggino bambino dentro è molto bello perché ti seguo da tanti anni prima al liceo e l'università
ora
ho un figlio è fantastico questo caso è simile coppia bambino alto così mi vedo uscire lombar
Impazziscono perché non sono aspettano che di qua o sei tu grida, non
Ci posso credere sapevo che di aver incontrato con un pensavo oggi un casino stanno di fatto ignorando
MI chino sulle ginocchia, e prima gli metto una mano sulla spalla e gli dico: che bel giubbotto che hai! come ti chiami?
marco
Conti amia e marco così è per esempio con le dita io vado alla madre che sorride qui inizia a fare domande dove va
E va in giro con la mamma ma che belle scarpe eccetera sicché bambino che un bambino non, si sa noi
Essere va e scappa
Del rom bar di corsa e mi spaventano quindi mi alzerò gli che ci parlava un'ora
E vedo che genitori però non seguono e mi dicono. Eh io ho visto il tuo video nel quale parlavi di non
So che del referendum. Del referendum e mi chiedono cose io dico loro sì possiamo parlare
del referendum possiamo parlare interessante prostro figlio è appena entrato al bar è che fate lasciatemi
Io dico un po scherzando ma sono preoccupato la madre mi guarda mi sorride e dice che non è con te
non è mica nostro figlio bello
Ma come non è vostro figlio sono un ora che sto molestando un bambino in mezzo alla strada vi
Vedono tutti c'è pure la vetrata la serata entro il padre
Ditemi qual con onde temi parlami. Del referendum ditemelo dopo ditemi quello che questo figlio questo bambino, non
È il tuo figlio è invece invece non mi hanno detto niente quindi semi incontrate c'è un bambino vicino vite vi
Subito non. È il nostro figlio perché non. Ho intenzione di molestare dei bambini ok sarà vantano youtube
Non, so mi volesse player però
Ok dunque
allora io
Ormai, l'ha raccontata. Io non. So cosa dirvi
Ringrazio I partecipanti che hanno voluto entrare nel mio bar e io spero di fare altri open bar in futuro
Spero di non di non sentire più
Ragazzi buon natale noi ci ci rivedremo sicuramente adesso tiro giù la serranda e
Wow wow wow